[MUSIC PLAYING]
In modern, mobile
applications, bitmaps
can account for a large
amount of memory churn.
Costly loading thumbnails,
user icons, and emoji sets
can provide your users with
a steady stream of media,
but it can also contribute to
some huge pauses for garbage
collection.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and for
temporarily allocated bitmaps,
there's a handy trick
that you absolutely
should be using to escape
these performance concerns.
See, bitmaps represent the
largest contiguous blocks
of memory that will
occupy your heaps, which
can create a lot of contention
to find free space when
a new one has been requested,
which, of course, then leads
to more GC events being kicked
off to free up and provide
that needed space.
Now, when you've got a
media-rich applications that's
providing lots of
images to the user,
these extra GC events
during image loading
can quickly eat into your
applications performance.
Thankfully, though,
you can fix this issue
by extending the concept
of object pools to bitmaps.
Object pools are
a common technique
for high-churn data types.
Now, effectively, when
you're done with an object,
rather than freeing it
back to the memory heap,
you keep a reference to it in
the list of available objects.
The next time you need a new
object of that same type,
you can repurpose the
existing object from the pool
rather than grabbing a brand
new one from the memory heap.
Extending this to your bitmaps,
though, it is a little tricky.
See, Android image-loading
APIs by default
will load your image data
and create new bitmap
on the heap for
them to reside in.
But you can actually
around this limitation.
Rather than creating
a brand new bitmap,
you can signal to the decoder to
use an existing piece of memory
to load that bitmap into.
This is easily done using
the inBitmap property
of your bitmap options object.
When you assign the inBitmap
property to an existing bitmap,
any of your decode
or load calls will
reuse that existing bitmap
for the incoming pixel data
rather than allocating
a new object
from the heap, which is
great, because it means
that for your awesome new
social media stream, where
the user starts scrolling
through 10,000 profile photos,
you don't need to create
10,000 separate bitmap objects.
Instead you only need to
allocate the maximum number
of bitmaps that could be
visible and just reuse
those new bitmaps as they
scroll onto the screen.
Now, this technique
comes with some caveats,
though, that you
need to be aware of.
Firstly, reused bitmaps have
a constraint with respect
to the physical size of
the existing bitmaps.
See, in SDK 18 and below,
the bitmap you're loading in
and the bitmap
you're reusing must
be the same exact size in order
for things to work properly.
In SDK 19 and above, this has
been relaxed a little bit,
in that your existing
bitmap can be
greater than or equal
to the same dimensions
of the incoming bitmap.
Secondly, know that while you
can reuse across pixel formats,
it's a pretty gnarly process.
A much easier approach is
to use separate bitmaps
for each unique pixel
format that you have.
For example, if you're
using a 565 or a 4444 image
in order to optimize
for memory space,
you shouldn't reuse that
space for an 8888 image later.
Trust me.
Madness waits there.
Oh, and to further
help out with this,
it might save you some time
to create an object pool
with common bitmap
sizes and formats
that you can reuse over the
life of your application,
reducing memory churn and
fragmentation even more.
But in truth, this problem
has been around awhile,
and lots of other people
have gone about solving it.
In fact the Glide
library already
has code to handle this
type of bitmap reuse
as well as a ton of
other functionality
that makes using bitmaps
on Android a world easier.
I mean, it's really good to know
how the basics of this stuff
work under the hood, but when it
comes to production level code,
it's usually a good idea to
lean on libraries where you can.
But this is just the start.
There's a whole load of other
things that you can take
advantage of to increase
your performance,
which is why you should check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content
and join the Google+ community
for tips from other developers
facing the same problems.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember--
Perfmatters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]